ieri ho fatto barbie dream house party e
probabilmente mezzo mondo ha pensato va
beh almeno fa vige non potrà mai portare
un contenuto più disturbante di questo è
impossibile
giochiamo
ragazzi miei non so se vi ricordate cupi
che cos'era che cosa non era niente
niente ho battuto la testa sono vivo lo
stesso creatori di colpi ha fatto sta
roba
cominciamo se una pentola nel nulla il
fantastico bella partenza distrutto non
so quanti anni di evoluzione del
cervello dell'homo sapiens capisco per
ragazzi allora in questo gioco che fatto
dal tizio che ha fatto che sono morto
chiarendo nella neanche intenzionale tra
di questo gioco si sei un uomo barbuto
con tanto fisico che deve
arrivare da qualche parte non ho ben
capito dove usando il martello come
slancio perché non ho le gambe per
muovermi devo fare forza come se fossi
maurizio merluzzo incazzato un capodanno
bene perfetto
ok fin qua devo agganciarmi alle cose ok
chiaro a mons
amo la narrazione oddio sto male c'è
anche la narrazione la come aiuto ma
porca vacca si concentri fratte tanto
non capisco ok no no no è difficilissimo
raga porca eva no malawi smettere di
parlare mi sede con c'è già è difficile
e sto gioco per cortesia ma io posso
saltare
porca vacca che figata
[Musica]
piano piano quasi un casino vaffan cuore
riuscita a cadere dopo un chilometro che
avevo fatto porca eva si chiamano in
questi momenti porca [ __ ] solo io sono
laico che fisica
aiuto calvi calmi tutti i siti tutti
fermi calmi aiuto aiuto non ci voglio
perfetto non è vero nella vita mai fa
possibile ma come fa a essere così
difficile sporca ma io mi ricordo che
cupi non aveva senso ma sta roba santo
iddio piano piano non c'era allora
funziona ti prego ti prego dai
ok no non è difficile secondo me se ti
impegni o era tanto incasinato piano di
uno come prima capire come hai fatto ad
esso perfetto ok madonna ma io prima ero
salito pure qualcuno che ti fa ho fatto
niente per porto c'è veramente in
crescita parti incredibile ragazzi se va
bene all'inizio visto già ok va bene non
lo so come sto facendo va bene va bene
va bene avere così bravo bravo fratello
si no
[Risate]
madonna rega cioè io veramente non posso
provare istinti omicidi per un
videogioco c'erano veramente senso
buttare ma ma ma vi se no non è vero non
è vero mai ve lo giuro su chi volete
ammazzo qualcuno cioè non è possibile
madonna madonna piano piano piano ti
prego ok no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no piano
pianissimo
ci sono poi ti di visitare lo sly
capitoli ti devi dare lo slancio quindi
sarebbe grazie a dio non sono ancora
caduto non ha veramente senso veramente
un anno è possibile che siamo ancora qua
l'inizio mi vuoi spiegare anni della mia
vita che cosa sono serviti solo per
giocare a questo schifo di porca vacca
schifosa laida canaja ha bisogno di un
attimo cioè vi giuro non so come ok
nel mirino no non ci arriva il caffè
aspetti aspetta madonna madonna che ero
arrivato dove è arrivato
porca vacca per non è vero ma è saltato
il caffè cimiteri sta dando veramente
fastidio schizzi che parla stai zitto
non è vero
madonna madonna madonna no perché non è
possibile fare quella parte lì perché
non si può non sia io ve lo giuro non si
aggancia c'è veramente no non è
possibile perché non riesco a fare
questa parte andiamo ma dai
cosa c'è di così dice ve lo giuro
e sali lì che schifo di problema
sì io sto male io sto male sto male sto
esercizi ti ammazzo ti ammazzo adotta un
bambino sano gesù ti prego ti prego
aiutami dio ma come cazzo di cane che mi
sta guardando da un'ora come dire ma che
cazzo sta facendo questo che non ce la
posso fare lo giusto che imprimono
finisco pensiero ma non pensavo mai a
una cosa del genere io ve lo dico
stai zitto per cortesia
fammi questo favore ti prego già un
casino avete seccato dalla dietro torno
indietro tutto il che potrebbe farmi
troppo ridere var la parte che la fisica
visto gioco una guarda guarda se cado
bravissimo
agganciati alla fine è difficile andare
avanti capito a fare un metro
ln come faccio ma cosa me ne frega di
come qualcosa di sci videogiochi tu ma
come faccio a servirla sopra scusatemi
ma la domanda è ma perché non mi possa
agganciare a niente capito come faccio a
la lampada ma va a cagare va a chi la
raggiunge la rampa a oggi
[Musica]
ecco la rappresentazione di questo gioco
di me basta partiamo dal quale prossimo
non basta c'è veramente io giuro il cane
è morto morto quando ho coperto webcam è
passata tipo un'ora e mezza sono tornato
qua mi sono calmato capitemi non posso
darvi l'antico capisco che non ho fatto
molto non me ne frega un ca mai stato
così isterico per un gioco per questa
roba poi basta
c'è veramente riuscita lernia
[Musica]